enemies because you take away this
this human aspect of somebody and you
expect them to keep their sanity
and i i was i was losing it i was
[ __ ]
losing it let me tell you why too
because number one i couldn't taste
which is one of my biggest joys
because when i caught it and i wasn't
sure that i had it 100 in the hotel
um i was just making sure i didn't want
to infect mario which was a good thing i
did go there
and then i tested again and lo and
behold i did have it after my taste went
away but i was like
but when i was in the hotel i was
telling myself like look five four
three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast quarantine edition
uh audio's a little [ __ ] up right now
because we're just doing it through the
computer
because your boy caught come in
you're a little bit too excited for that
oh man let me let me tell you something
dude
it's funny i've been really quiet about
my coven situation
just because i know bart came out with
the video and then tim came out with
this thing and
everybody knows that you know we got it
from luhan bart
[Laughter]
are you you're as bad as uh mark our
outgoing president right now i just call
him wuhan bart
look at the way i look i'm asian i'm
fine oh man okay
all right all right ching chong cops
[Laughter]
you're gonna you're gonna take every
comedic license out hey guys just so you
guys know
um you want me to tell them a thing with
dave japal said
and and trump oh yeah joe all right all
right
well david was unfamiliar with uh when
the president was saying
um some very racist comments and when he
called the coronavirus to come through
and i was like man dave did you see this
like he wrote it on this thing
he said this reporter confronted him as
i'm telling david
this story instead of him being uh and
this is before david david sappell came
out and said this but uh
david just started laughing he's like
that shit's hilarious
now and that was the moment when i knew
my friend was more comedian than
you know than uh asian uh individual who
should be offended by the racism behind
this
label it just came out of the wrong
person's mouth that's all that it is
because that's a pretty [ __ ] fire
disc that's hilarious dude
well he said that and then uh and then a
few months or weeks later then dave
chappelle
like said that's just hilarious and then
i was like damn dave chappelle and
and david silver are kind of in that
same like wavelength right now
i came out with the joke before i did
and that was forever a dave chappelle
joke [ __ ]
i know and i was like damn i mean i
think you transition man you and dave
are vibing the same way you hear the
same piece of news and you thought about
he's like damn that's hilarious
he's definitely influenced the way that
i think so it's like i'm just
a a little blip of what he is
because you know you know when i first
started doing youtube and stuff all that
inside jokes with all dave chappelle
jokes and everybody knew it so it was
like yeah
we always borrow we always borrow styles
from the people that we appreciate oh
100
man yeah but i've had hope it's such a
weird thing because you know
i didn't you know i'm relatively careful
like i work can 95
mass uh not around a lot of people and
so
you know there was the [ __ ] mike
python fight and i just had to go see
the titan fight
and then uh bart invited me over to go
go to the tyson fight and the weird
thing is i usually when he invites me
over to
to go to a fight uh it's usually it's
like most of the time it's just me him
and geo
so there's not a lot of people but then
i didn't know how many people were going
and i didn't realize there was a lot
then you know tim was there i was there
which you know tim and tim already uh
mentioned
so i'm not saying anything new but when
we went there i was like oh [ __ ]
and a part of me was like i shouldn't be
here you know
i'm like i don't like this and then lo
and behold
i i started feeling funky around like uh
friday night
and then i canceled everything on
saturday and then
look so this this was uh this was the
thanksgiving friday right
or or this past friday this was this uh
past friday so like 10 days ago
and then i was like um i'm feeling a
little funky
so i decided to cancel everything on
saturday because i didn't feel
symptomatic i just didn't feel myself
you know and i remember other people
telling me like
one of the things that they saw that was
a symptom was feeling weak
and fatigue fatigue is very common
exactly and it's a very apparent type of
fatigue too so if you guys are out there
and you know you're like what is
feeling tired mean you're going to know
what it feels like it feels off
it feels like your body is just not it's
not things aren't firing at all
cylinders
and so uh didn't have a sore throat
didn't have a cough i didn't even have a
fever i didn't have any of that stuff i
just felt
tired and then uh i cancelled everything
i stayed at home until i could get a kid
and then we were doing the in-home kit
test and because i know how far you have
to go because i've got
i've gotten the test like seven or eight
times already yeah
that [ __ ] actually [ __ ] hurt but i
saw the uh it's like a pregnancy test
right so you get the
two lines means you have it one line
means you don't so for some reason i
read that two lines meant that you
didn't have it
and so i saw two lines i was like your
boy is good and i was chilling in the
house
i was chilling and then i stopped for a
second i'm like
i bet you i misread this hold on a
second i went back i'm like
[ __ ] i got it so i gotta um i went and i
got a hotel
i left i let the staff know and they
were okay with it they just nobody just
came into the room so i don't know if
they were hurting for customers or
something but
um yeah how's the how's marianne how's
she doing
she's good so she tested like three
times um since then so it's been about
10 days and she's tested multiple times
since
and uh she has no symptoms so it's good
that's good
14. see what happens um i've been
hearing that
um people uh
you were telling me right i think it was
you you told me that people in the
household
it seems that other people aren't
getting it except for like maybe one or
two people
yeah i mean i think it's you you know
again
everything we're saying is like is this
like such a moving target because we're
learning as we're going right like i
think if anybody watches foul chief
anybody watches like
you know cdc fda like all these all this
knowledge
is coming in and then a lot of
information get from
like people like you like you know
you're like you said i didn't get the
short i didn't get the sore throat i
didn't get the cops
you know i asked fatigue and whether
whatever other symptoms
so i just moved to new york city and um
the clinic where i work at in the bronx
one of the places that was hardest hit
with um covet mortalities
yeah yeah and you know and it's it's
there's a lot of factors that go into it
but
it's predominantly um you know black and
brown so a lot of these minority
communities which
we already know that they are at a you
know
disadvantage when it comes to just kind
of um
infrastructure and there's a lot of
things that are set up against them so
when kova hit
you just you see a lot of people dying
disproportionately
um anyways um one of the things that was
interesting every almost everybody in my
the clinic that i work at um covet went
through there like a wildfire
um yeah so
they don't know who had it first but one
of my colleagues um
she had it and and her husband um
you know he you know whether it's love
or
or pride or whatever he was just like i
ain't nope i'm sleeping in the same
room we're going in this together you
know that that old love you know
anyways and and she said you know he
never got it and he tested
a few times and they did antibodies
later on and she came back positive she
she had a positive swab and she had
positive antibodies she never had a
positive swab and never had positive
antibiotics and they shared a bed the
whole time that she had it i wouldn't
break i don't recommend it
yeah you know but but i mean but that's
an interesting phenomenon we're just
saying that
um some people and their partners never
got it you know like like one person had
it and they didn't they didn't even
split apart so
there's just so much and then i have a
number of patients who are telling me
symptoms i don't even know about
um you know like we know about we know
about like the
sore throat the cough the fevers fatigue
is very common with like you know just
viral illnesses in general like the flu
um a lot of gi stuff happens with this
so like
diarrhea diarrhea diarrhea um and then
um a few of my patients
talked about like their hair thinning so
you know that's not something that we
talk about either oh
when this will tell me that i was like
no
[Laughter]
join the club baby about to get hats i'm
about to be chilling
how about y'all bad black people look
good ball not me full i look like i made
like a spiritual mom choice if i did
that [ __ ]
bro we're about to get these skully's
together would be good
yeah bro straight us don't worry scully
oh i would die laughing i think the
worst part for me was
the um the loss of taste because i can't
taste yeah
so you know for me obviously a huge part
of my career is predicated on my palette
so uh just yesterday for the first time
not
not all of his back but like maybe two
percent three percent of its back so
i was having a video call and as we were
uh we were doing like a zoom dinner type
of thing
with a couple of friends of ours i
couldn't taste [ __ ] so i ordered food
and i'm just ordering soup just because
it's the easiest to eat i can't really
taste anything
eating it whatever and then i went to go
get this yogurt
and i put it in my mouth and i was like
this lightly tastes like banana
and i looked at the yogurt thing and it
said banana and i swear to god your boy
teared up i was like yo i could taste
again that [ __ ] was [ __ ] crazy
here's the thing man and i think like
this is
this perspective for me right because
i've been in you know away from people
for 10 days like
i i think problematically a lot of
people are saying these small things
like
we already know like you could affect
people who are elderly people who have
underlying conditions that's a huge
issue right
but then when when people talk about
somebody who's young and they're like
well if i give it to somebody who's
young they're going to survive
well at the same time who the [ __ ] wants
to be in quarantine for 10 days like
mentally it's really really difficult
it's [ __ ] hard
you know and i think like i've never
been tested mentally like this
um because i'm i'm not i i am kind of an
introverted to a certain extent but i
like to go outside like that's a huge
part of my being i need to be outside if
i don't i start to lose my [ __ ] mind
this is probably the closest thing i've
ever felt a depression like i've never
ever felt like this before and to be
sitting in a room knowing that i can't
be around people because i'm concerned
i'm gonna give it to somebody else
and on top of that too if i got this
virus during a time i had to do a show
i would have lost a [ __ ] ton of money
too so it goes beyond just you know
somebody uh dying or you know being
fatally ill from this affects them
mentally
like and you know and i started getting
like uh i didn't know that the lower
back pain thing was uh was a symptom
my uh that's your muslim muscle lakes
you know yeah people have it different
places but yeah man
how are you doing now the the the muscle
legs are gone
uh i got a little bit of my taste back
but definitely don't feel like myself a
hundred percent like i don't feel like i
could bike
you know the 15 20 miles that i normally
do get it you got to
ease back in man did you uh did you ever
get a fever
i might have but i would probably slept
through it
you didn't have a thermometer or
anything no but i don't remember
oh i had a [ __ ] crazy headache the uh
the headache was weird it was a very
unique headache too it wasn't
it felt like sinus pressure but that i
didn't have a plug nose i didn't have a
stuffy nose
but it was it was sharp pain throughout
the sinus and around the
head here and then i took tylenol it
didn't do [ __ ]
so nothing was helping it out i just had
to just
just bite down on the mouth guard and
just go through it
so when i uh that headache part in the
first three days was probably the worst
part about it um super sensitive to
light
couldn't it didn't feel like a migraine
didn't feel like a headache it was
something unique on its own
yeah yeah i know man it's it's just
i i know that we're going to be studying
this virus for you know and and it and
and the complications from it for many
years
like like we don't understand hopefully
you know we don't see a lot of
transformation in this thing staying
around like i i have
um you know i have some hope
in kind of what we're seeing with uh
moderna
and pfizer and all that stuff but you
know i
we also know that some viruses change
um and and we'll see what happens we'll
see what happens as far as like this
virus in time
but if even if like we if we survive all
this
vaccine comes out we do great we're
going to be looking into this virus and
like
this variety of symptoms that cause in
different people
just different strains because now
there's talk that the strain that came
to new york was
from europe right as opposed to directly
from
um china um and and so that a lot of the
people came from europe
brought the strain that was in new york
so it you know and then i think
when you think about just kind of
geography and the proximity of asia to
like california and the west coast
um it would be make more sense that
certain strains probably came directly
from that side of the world
so you know it so i i'm i i have a
suspicion that scientists doctors um
everybody is going to be looking into
the variations of this
uh virus for many years and kind of like
why it caused so many different symptoms
in different people complications some
people have problems with like we talked
about
like fatigue taste smell some people
have the classic symptoms that they
originally warned us about some people
didn't have anything
some people got crazy sick some people
did not
and then what we talked about earlier
some people's partners were
good they slept in the same room they
talked to them you know and nothing got
transmitted so there's so much
that we don't know um but i think i'm
you know i'm glad to hear that you're
doing better dog you know i mean
i know that you just got that that
netflix show and you know i know that we
plan to retire together and leave our
women you don't have to retirement
you know how [ __ ] sad i am as a human
being like i i think day
three or day four for about three to
four hours a day
i looked outside my hotel window and i
just looked at people
like a fat cat i know why [ __ ] cats
do that [ __ ]
i just sat there watching people for
three hours a day
like just looking because you know you
you could only do so much like computer
work
you know right when you wake up so i'm
sitting there just looking at people
walking around i'm like you [ __ ]
lucky sons of [ __ ]
just imagine dude just imagine like uh
people who are stuck in hospital beds
for
multiple stays you know and or just like
even people like who are who are locked
up and are in solitary confinement
you know like even people who haven't
even people haven't been convicted like
you know khalif browder and all that
like i mean
it's just it's just it's such a it's
such a dehumanizing thing to be
iceland for extended periods of time
yeah man it's so weird because i was i
was you know sitting in this hotel i
know it sounds so like first world
problem right but there are certain
things that humans need
right obviously socialization i think is
one of them it's very key
sunlight and activity you take that away
from a human being
like it's like a little bit of your
spirit dies now i'm looking at this
prison system like
you know i know these people some of
these people are really hard on
criminals
but fun man like i don't know if i would
wish this on some of my worst enemies
because
you take away this this human aspect of
somebody and you expect them to keep
their sanity
and i i was i was losing it i was
[ __ ]
losing it let me tell you why too
because number one i couldn't taste
which is one of my biggest joys
because when i caught it and i wasn't
sure that i had it 100 in the hotel
um i was just making sure i didn't want
to infect mario which was a good thing i
did go there and then i tested again and
lo and behold i did have it after my
taste went away but i was like this
podcast is brought to you by
cbd farmhouse if you haven't heard of
cbd farmhouse
well you will very soon because cbd
farmhouse when it comes to their
products stands out above the rest
and i'm not just saying that because i
actually use a lot of their products
before they became a a sponsored brand i
was actually using them even before that
so
the the freezing roll-on is money
specifically if you're sore or if you
have some kind of eggs i use it all the
time specifically i kick box and i work
out
and that has been a savior if you
haven't had their gummies
use it when you're feeling anxious if
you have anxiety attacks a lot
cbd gummies are a godsend and on top of
that if i just want to sleep really well
i eat one of the gummies right before i
sleep and it just helps me to
relax for all my genius brain listeners
you can get
15 off any order if you just plug in
code brain at checkout that's at
cbdfarmhouse.com
once again cbdfarmhouse.com
and use codebrain to get 15 off today
as long as i have my taste i'm fine i'm
gonna just eat up
jack off and i'll be perfectly fine and
so i just sat there
i ordered lemon pepper wings blue cheese
dressing
and uh a bacon cheeseburger
i sit down i drink my sprite i could
taste it
cool i have a bite of the lemon pepper
wing i'm like that's a little bland
whatever
i go for the second wing i eat it
nothing
my [ __ ] heart sank i was like yo my
taste is gone so all i got left is jack
it up
and let me tell you something when
you're depressed it's not even an option
on the table
so i'm just sitting there like i got
nothing i got nothing
and your boy don't even watch porn
either so i'm like this sucks
i don't i don't know why in my in my
head i'm thinking of that dave chapel
uh story when you talk about louis ck
and it's like
just like sad
dude oh bro uh yeah nah man it's it's
it's definitely you know i think it's
dude i mean i
i think there's a couple things that are
are going to be very formative for
people of our generation you know um i
don't compare this to the great
depression but i think
you know this pandemic and the
quarantine is going to have
uh definite effects on our socialization
when we come out of this
how people date how people go out like
you know um how people feel about
illness
people's cleanliness i hope um i feel
like we're gonna start wearing masks you
know like we uh
people in america used to be always just
looking at asia like why are they
wearing masks and now i feel like
everybody like for every like man i'm
actually as a doctor i'm kind of excited
like next you know after kovit is
settled
and just flu seasons coming around
people just like masking up i'll be
laughing
look at this public health look at all
these people taking these uh
you know each other's health into yeah
these mass companies made a killing dude
like a [ __ ] killing dude you know a
part
part of me like ethically
i don't own any stock in any like
pharmaceuticals but i wish i had some
money in fires
that's all i'm saying i don't have any
disclaimer
but uh but if i did man you may not see
me no more you might be like yo let's do
a zoom i'm out here on the beach like
what's up
where are you at oh the bronx
yo why is everybody i'm always been i
don't know anything about like the whole
vaccine thing right because
um you know there's a whole bunch of
memes and things popping up saying like
oh like if you take this vaccine right
now there's a lot of adverse effects
what what what are the like what are the
downsides of being like the first person
to take a vaccine is it really that
big of an issue or are people just kind
of like blowing out of proportion
no no i i think so um you know i
i think it's natural um
that people have questions right
especially if we're introducing
something that
didn't exist a year ago two people
and were saying like hey we want to
vaccinate
a good majority like what what's a joe
biden's thing 100 million people uh
vaccinations in 100 days or something
like that yeah um
right so i think um for the last decade
or so
we've been seeing um a lot of people
like some movements
uh questioning the validity of
vaccinations again
i would say a lot of like the caveat for
a lot of these vaccines that we've
had you know they've been around for a
very very very very long time there was
a
paper that came out in in um i don't
remember what years but it was
probably a little under a decade ago in
the lancet
it's like uh the uk's biggest like
science journal
um and at the time um somebody was
correlating um vaccinations and
immunizations with autism
and um and then people were saying like
oh it's gonna cause autism and there's
like a lot of stuff and
and all that and since then that paper
was
uh debunked or revoked and then that
person
uh lost their medical degree and all you
know their license and all that
um um and and a lot of
papers contrary to that have proven like
there is no correlation
the thing is that like around the time
that kids are getting immunization
around like
you know a few months like you know they
get it at
like two four six months and then you
know in the first
two years you're getting a bunch of
vaccines and then we start seeing the
development
and and the timing that we see of like
autism kind of coming around like
early is probably around like three-ish
so like that
like people started saying like it must
be these vaccines my baby was fine but
we gave them all the stuff and now they
developed this
um so there was like a timing thing but
there was never really there was no
evidence and there's lots of money that
was put into trying to figure out if
they're
because people have some legitimate
concerns like parents who
had kids that had like autism and
legitimate concerns like did i do this
to my child
which i think any yeah and then and then
all the evidence pointed to no
right so i think since then there's been
a big
like question the norm of like
vaccinations on all these things
um but i think as a society we can't
um you know underestimate the benefit
that we've had like we've got
rid of polio right like uh we've gotten
rid of
like small books all these different
things that like that we've eradicated
because we've really really good and
then we started seeing a resurgence of
certain things like measles remember
like that disney i think it's disney
land break like outbreak
yeah cause then you have these diseases
that have very high infect infect
uh infect like infection rates like in
the upper 90s
yeah um yeah yeah it's that infectious
right so and but then you stop
vaccinating children you lose what
everyone's trying to achieve which is
like herd immunity
um so you know all that go you know all
that
feeds into what we're in now where
people are still like what the effort we
putting into our our bodies and then we
have social media
everybody who has an opinion can put out
a video right you don't necessarily have
you don't have to be an expert to put
out a video
so you could put you could put up you
know q9 people could put up this
uh anti-vaxxer put up this um you know
the head of the fda could put up a video
but it could just
drown down everything it may not be as
sexy you know may not be as well
produced
um and and it goes back to that we
talked about what was like
denzel like it's the the standard of
news is no longer accuracy
and you know fidelity is it's
what's first what comes out you know
what's hitting you so there's a lot of
misinformation a lot of doubt a lot of
all this mixed together
so in short you know
the the the vaccine is still held to a
very
high rigor of testing and there's a lot
of evidence that needs to be
passed before something will get
approval um
there's usually a um you know after the
the organizations like pfizer approve um
you know make a vaccine do their own
internal
like tests there's usually um
a rep like a repeat of those tests by
an external party like so like the fda
or like other organizations that are
like hey can we recreate
the same results with the vaccine
and then there's usually a period where
you follow the results
um after you know like after something
like after medication has been
out in the public then there's always
you always go back and you check to make
sure it's efficacious it's safe
right you you have a you have you have a
group now that you're able to do
you could be as large as like a couple
thousand people could be as small as
like a few hundred
um but you know i i think
the part that i think what i keep
hearing about a lot of the concern
is for people like well we don't know
what the long-term effects are
and and and i think i think that's
fair to uh you know to to have a certain
amount
of uh you know question
um about what are the long-term effects
um
you know i think but i think what we're
seeing
is is that most of these techniques and
most of these things have been used
before
so um people are looking at it and being
like hey you know
this should be safe we put it in like a
big group of people
we saw some sore arms we saw some mild
symptoms
it's pretty efficacious i think it's
better than the alternative when we're
losing more
you know 3 000 people a day um
so so it starts becoming it's like you
know i we don't
we don't have a crystal ball we can't
see all the complications that are going
to come from it
but right now i think what most experts
are believing
is that they're going to be mild if
anything like if you look at um i think
the
the flu vaccine i think the there's a
there's immediate risk
of like anaphylaxis with that is like
your your throat closing up
you can't breathe and what people need
an epipen for like you know people
have really bad peanut allergies yeah
there's like uh i think it's like one in
one million
so for every like million people who get
it one person will have an episode of
anaphylaxis
um so but i think
for for society when you worry about
how these viruses can kill the people
like you know people
like we've lost over 200 000 people yeah
um
you know um you start thinking about i
was like well one in one million could
have this life-threatening complication
immediately but
for the most part people may have some
life
you know cold-like symptoms or sore harm
but i think that is better than
you know losing a whole swath of our
population
shutting down our you know all the
interactions that are so important to
us feeling like a community like people
so
i i i think that that's part of the the
question right so
i get i get where some of the concern
comes from you know i
i understand you're just like well you
know we haven't seen this thing it's new
right um but i think people there are
testing in
a lot of people they've tested a lot of
people like they've already
it's already started in the uk doctors
are going to get it first
i hear i hear the the current
president's
living presidents minus uh sans uh el
trimpito
are gonna receive it as well um i don't
think jimmy carter is gonna get it
though
he's still alive right i think so yeah i
don't know i feel like a thousand years
old
goddamn yeah i think he's alive but i
think he definitely
had some um close calls in the
past few years yeah but yeah man i don't
sorry that was a long answer but
you know i get where the it's just like
there's a lot of history to
what the anti-vaxx movement came from
yeah and then and i think there are some
concerns that are
that are very extreme right that are
that that you're like
hey that's you know that's
really far-fetched and then i think
there's like the everyday kind of like
hey you know
i get your argument i understand um
i'm still a little hesitant i don't know
if i want to do this
and you know and i get and i get those
people too like they're not the time
they're not the people who think there's
like a chip in the vaccine or
or there's gonna turn them into zombies
or anything like that they're just like
hey like
i get it the fda did a bunch of testing
they had an independent like committee
who
ruled it has to be safe there you know
there's multiple committees on different
continences in different countries
that have ruled it to be safe and are
implementing it to start the vaccination
process for their
societies um so i get a bunch of
scientists are on board and say hey
like it looks like the studies that
these companies are presenting
are you know they they are what they say
they are
they're as effective as they say they
are you know so
we got to greenlight it so it's one of
those things so you know that so
there'll be a lot of people who are
going to want the vaccine
initially and a lot of people who are
going to be like i will wait
and i can i get what and i get where
they're coming from i think for me like
personally i'm going to get it
like i i work with a lot of people i'm
here in new york
um you know i uh my parents aren't the
youngest
in the world and and you know and i
would feel
devastated if i gave it to one of my
patients or my
partner or my family yeah
well you can always just get covered
like me i got the vaccine in my system
maybe
you know how it is i can't be killed
in that week i could better lift my arms
oh my god [ __ ]
not exactly how it works but okay that's
how it works dude
that's not that's not exactly okay don't
don't um don't go out don't play in the
street or anything like that
you know my brother's saying that uh
people are uh
they're asking for blood donations for
people who've had it and
is that true yeah i mean so i think
they're
so yeah so there is uh
it's it's it's like the the plasma so i
think like uh i think trump got that
treatment actually
um so so people the the thought is
if you've had it in your system spin it
down get some your plasma there's a
bunch of good stuff in there immune cell
systems
wise and your body has uh
has developed to kind of fight the virus
so i think they're fine
finding that there is a benefit to
people um
getting those treatments um again you
know the
i think i think that i don't know i'm
old school i think the best treatment is
prevention right like so it's
it's masking up gloving up if
you if you if you are don't go to
[ __ ] tyson
boxing parties and share food you
[ __ ] idiot
this is when you should this is when you
should this podcast is brought to you by
better help is there something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
my friends i have been there and trust
me it is not a happy place to be but you
don't have to be there
see mental health is something that a
lot of people haven't really focused on
especially during this pandemic right
now where
honestly you're kind of just stuck with
your thoughts especially if you're just
at home
see betterhelp will assess your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
and you can start communicating in under
48
hours it's awesome and remember guys
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional counseling
done securely on line i personally
love online therapy because i could do
it when i need it
and i could do it here at my house
sometimes some of us don't feel
comfortable talking to a person that we
don't know in person to person
because maybe you guys have anxiety like
i do so guys visit betterhelp.com
genius that's better h-e-l-p and join
over
1 million people who have taken charge
of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional special offer for my genius
brain listeners you can get 10 off your
first month at
betterhelp.com genius once again
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-com
genius today i should not promote
pirating huh
you know because i could clearly afford
to buy this fight
you know i'm like uh he already said
you see that you see that nate robinson
one man i was worried for him i was like
i saw i saw that and then like um
somebody had
had found it on the internet i don't
know who that person is anyways
so i thought it i thought it glitched i
was like what's the guy i saw the thing
and then i saw falls like oh my god
my internet just died that people got
knocked down to the underground railroad
dude
i was worried i was worried man i was
like damn he
like because there's certain posturing
that you worry about and he's
like the arm position and the stiffness
i was i was literally worried about like
brain injury yeah i mean like for him
too
this is the weird thing too like number
one that
that white boy can box now like he's
been training for like two years
with some really really great boxing
trainers and that kid's about that life
is he pro boxer level no absolutely not
and everybody knows this
but is his brother is his brother
fighting floyd yeah his brother's
[ __ ] boxing floyd mayweather dude
like and there's this whole debate about
whether it's really good for the sport
or not i don't i don't know
what it's gonna get it's good for floyd
he's about to get paid
that's what it is how much more money
does this [ __ ] need dude
i don't know i saw him skating around
uh i think like him and swiss beats or
whatever they had like a little
challenge just skating around they're
like garages i
saw him with all his cars skating around
i was like my man
why do you need a flex like this i don't
know i don't even know why he needs this
fight i mean i guess he wants to stay as
relevant as possible even though he's
like a boxing hall of famer
but it's weird because you said that kid
jake paul he's he's like you're in my
height he's like six foot one nate
roberts is like five they say he's five
eight he's five seven that guy's short
as [ __ ] i've seen him in person
like he's like five seven at most uh
jake paul i think pro you know he they
think they weighed in like 180 or
something like that but
off off training off the scale he's
probably close to like one ninety two
hundred pounds
and then he said or somebody who's five
seven who has who's trained boxing maybe
three months
it's like what what the [ __ ] was going
to happen like you're literally twice
this dude's size he's trained
four times longer and then you know he
wins this boxing match and they're like
oh
i'm like of course like of course what
was gonna happen you know they're like
oh but nate nate robinson's uh uh
a basketball athlete have you seen
basketball players fight on the court
they all suck
you know did i say did you i think i saw
what for like putting like meta world
peace in there
something else like god well metal piece
it still is [ __ ] hilarious the
mineral piece is huge too
man yeah i mean i was like well if
you're gonna
fight an nba player then get one with
some reach on them
yeah and you might as well give metal
world peace at least a year to train
yeah yeah no i mean i i think yeah we
saw that i was just like i was like
you know the athleticism doesn't cross
like that
yeah did you appreciate snoop dogg's
commentary though
snoop dogg was [ __ ] funny man this
one was like he was like it's like my
two uncles finding a barbecue
i was like yeah this is like hilarious
it was dude i mean that's literally what
it was like
man but tyson was uh thomas was a
beastly
i still see him yesterday he hit some
dips i was like i was like i was
and then did you see the interview at
the end wait why was anybody worried
about me
that was the part that had me dying left
he was
genuinely hurt he sat there he was like
okay
he has been boxed in three years i i
haven't boxing 15 how come nobody's
worried about me
and i looked at his face he was actually
hurt
bro i was like i was shocked when he
said i was like i'm sorry
i mean yeah i mean like i think we in
our hearts we've always been like it's
iron mike he's bulletproof he's like
he's a beast like he's like
everybody's worried about roy
everybody's like oh roy's gonna get
murdered by mike
and then everybody's like what about me
and i was like damn yeah it wasn't about
me i haven't fighted 15 years
i was like damn i chill bro like your
feelings hurt and stuff
mike tyson still scares the [ __ ] out of
me he's going to find out i keep
imitating him and beat my ass
nah man i hear he uh he smokes a lot man
why not he's chiller
so hopefully just you know just just
sponsor his product just plug his
product you'd be ah
he's uh it's interesting though watching
like all these old boss because i never
really got into boxing like that so i
never got to see
you know mike tyson box box like during
the time that he was boxing because
i think he won his championship when we
were like born
so like like 1987 1988 around there
so oh yeah i don't remember what the
year was where we had the famous like
ear bite but i remember being old enough
to like to like see a clip of me like
yeah i remember i remember being old
enough when that happened yeah and i was
like
i wanted to get it but my parents
wouldn't pay that kind of money for
pay-per-view they're like
none of us would none of our parents
would you was doing that [ __ ] through a
black box
i know i know that's what i was trying i
was like dad just like you know your
homie got the black box get the black
he's like he's like i will not risk my
family for
this tyson fight i was like i was like
dad just
do you love me
i like how that's that's what he draws a
line a black box
my dad did some shady things but i swear
to god he got he
hired my dad had a jamaican on deck for
any kind of repair that what
went down in my house he's like i'll go
get my friends this guy is not certified
to do plumbing he'd be like
he's like like john man i i can fix it
for you
and then the next thing i know dad's
like you can't flush it all the way
gotta go just a little quarter
stipulation just let it hang there for a
while and then a flush and i'm like
damn why can't you just pay for a repair
man all the way and he's like no
they charge too much it's ridiculous i
know your dad's a very very very funny
man i still can't believe he's a
security guard
like i know you i don't know what your
dad's pretty good
that this is this is that's that's his
like favorite career he's just walk
around talking to people
like if things go down he ain't chasing
nobody
that's exactly what i'm saying i know
you're dead somebody jack something your
dad just like
it is what it is but he would be like
i seen him he has a man
you know he was white what else what
else uh can you describe him as
i had this
blue or green or something kind of shirt
that's a great description he was gay
like how do you know he was gay
i know he is gay like all right dude
i mean he thought we were gay i mean i
don't know his gate out
his gaydar unless we have an
announcement for people today david
you know what let me tell you something
my stock would go up
i found out recently you know because
i'm in quarantine i'm reading all this
other [ __ ] but there was like an article
that was put out
i forgot who the celebrity was but i
guess he was supposed to announce
uh sam smith and he referred to him as a
he and i guess sam smith doesn't
identify as
a he him now oh is he is he no longer
is does he is no longer gender binary or
i don't think so anymore but i didn't
know but i was like oh [ __ ]
when did he do this i think i heard
about that but i mean i don't
follow sam smith as closely as some of
my other favorite celebrities cause he
came out as gay
so he was a him oh he's uh he's
he's not male or female he is something
of the other yeah so he's not in the
binary so it's not even
one or one or the other camp so it was
kind of not conforms to him as a that
is that nor a day is it there or that
they
they uh there's a lot of different ones
but i think um
they is as well made ones yeah they them
is one of the more common ones
see this is this is what i'm saying like
this is going to be a new thing
for you know how the previous generation
had to get used to the [ __ ] that we had
we were coming up with
now we have to get used to this part
because this wasn't a part of our stuff
growing up now so now we have to be
educated on
the pronoun stuff so i mean if if we had
to like i mean just think about like our
parents generation like
you had to like talk to them about like
like homosexuality
like you're just thinking about that
like like how you have to be like you
know like
no it's not like a choice like they
didn't like
be like oh they're rebelling so they're
going to decide to be gay today
you know like that's that's something
that we had to talk to our parents about
for some of us and then and then and
then and so i'm sure like now
for us who didn't grow up with a lot of
the if we didn't have the fortune of
having friends who represented a whole
spectrum of
like identification as far as like
gender then now
we're getting educated so yeah we adapt
and i'll have it's going to be
interesting for because um
i know one of my friends kids they're in
college right now
and when uh during orientation they
introduce their name
and also now their pronoun so what is
your name
what is your major and then what's your
pronoun and then oh like in
like in college in college and i think
like because this is something that's so
new
uh he was a little upset because like in
front of the whole class or just like
like turn it in
in the dorm in the dorm oh okay
so they're doing like the dorm thing and
they basically they had to
introduce themselves as who they are and
then announce their pronouns
so this kid didn't know what was going
on he's not he's not about that he's not
so much about that he just doesn't know
what this whole pronoun thing is right
it's relatively new
it's not something that he was ever ever
had to be conscious of and so
he was in the class and they're like he
goes what is that you know and then
people looked at him like this dirty
look
like you know kind of you know a little
upset and he goes i don't know what you
mean by
what is like aren't you a is it like
what do you mean like
he was trying to ask and being
inquisitive but he didn't know what was
going on and nobody was explaining to
him they were just kind of giving him
side eyes like
well you know you know people also have
to understand like if they didn't grow
up around this or they don't know or
wasn't brought up to them they're not
going to [ __ ] know this is new stuff
this is all new
and yeah i think that there has to be a
little patience to that learning process
yeah and
you know the problem with some with a
lot of people now is that they don't
they don't get it
you you were just like that person not
too long ago so how [ __ ] dare you
get angry at somebody for not knowing
because they're not knowledgeable
about something that you didn't know
that long ago either so
people like to you know have their nose
up and judge other people and they'd
rather chastise them and
give them an opportunity to learn which
is so [ __ ] up and i think the cool
thing about the whole sam smith
situation just to wrap it back
he you know he he was like hey it's all
good like you know you called me a he
you didn't know
i just i just appreciate that you tried
and that's it which is dope you know i
appreciate that because it creates great
conversation you know
yeah you know and there's like a there's
so many layers to this i think like when
i when i think about it i could only
tie it back to like your own personal
stories right like so i think
um for people who've never been around
black people
right like people will have some some
questions for me
and and definitely like
not every black person has to be the
educator for you
right like i think there's lots of lots
of people who are very tired and very
just like i don't want
to to explain why i am upset about
some of what's going on with the police
what's going on
in you know a state that's you know 15
states away from me
why that connects to me why that makes
me scared why that makes me scared for
my siblings for my children whatever
right um but you know i think
there has to be some of us who are
patient enough to be able to
like just like you know meet people
where they are and and
and i think and i think those are the
the
i think that's the true strength of
living in a country as diverse as the
united states is that you just have so
many
different people who have from different
walks of life and if you meet it
and if you meet ignorance with um with
an openness to
education and of course i'm not saying
like um
you know not someone coming at you who's
threatening your very existence that's a
whole different thing but if but if
someone's
coming at you with like a general like i
don't know i don't understand this
can you tell me a little bit more and
and you and you and you feel like you
can
be safe and sharing some of that
information i think it makes for a
better world
i mean also the person that uh
misgendered sam smith is uh shawn mendes
he's a musician right
i feel like oh yeah he did he did he did
with the camilla cabello or something
like that
yeah yeah that's right that's right yeah
and you know sam sam smith basically i
understand that sean may not have known
that um that sam smith but what
but why did no one correct them somebody
tweeted but you know like this is like
twitter is such a [ __ ] toxic place
right like somebody
on twitter is the chat rooms is it chat
rooms of old
yeah that's exactly what it was like
deshawn mendes just missed gender stan
smith four times in a row
really like come on how are you gonna
get mad at the dude for [ __ ] you're like
into that
first of all him coming out as uh
non-binary
it's it's recent you know it's like it's
like this
if i you know me as david for many years
right
and i don't know where i told you hey
call me pete from now on and then you
call me david like three of
the do i go like yo what the [ __ ] i just
told you my name is pete you [ __ ]
you know but it's like am i not gonna
give somebody the grace
like oh he's been calling me david for
[ __ ]
whatever 30 years you know should i get
mad at him for [ __ ] it up same thing
with
with sam smith he came out as a gay male
he was male he referred to himself as he
for the longest time
it's only until recent that he became a
day and an attempt so it's going to take
a while for it to adjust
for you to come out and attack somebody
like that it's not going to create good
conversation this is what young people
don't understand
you are not perfect like you you keep
judging people and getting mad at them
like this it only causes division
and i'm so sick of this [ __ ] ugh it
makes me angry
yeah yeah i mean i i think there is
definitely uh
there's people who are really quick to
get angry on your behalf
and that i mean like like some people
because some people come out
and like and you know i'm sure there's
definitely valid situations but people
come up and be like
how dare you ask him about his how he
his stance on black lives matter why he
doesn't like
so-and-so xyz i'm like i could explain
let me have this conversation you know
and
and and and um you know i think
the conversation is the only place where
that's how ignorance has changed right
like if there's one thing like if you're
ambushed at a table and you're like
the black date for a very like a full
caucasian family in the middle of the
south and you're worried about your
safety
that's maybe a whole different situation
but if you're like literally just having
a conversation with the co-worker who
didn't grow up in a very diverse place
then it's like it's like how will this
person know that's my that's always my
things like
like i could get mad i could get upset
but that person is gonna be frustrated
and they might
get some you know they might feel a type
of way because
every time they talk about this you
should people get mad and upset at them
so they get mad and upset at them and
that becomes like you said more divisive
and it doesn't lead to unification so i
think education gives you opportunity
to bring people together yeah and it's
just like a it's just very problematic
that i see
online it's you know being angry and
being like like socially upset is the
cool thing to do now
rather than like common sense would
dictate hey people are going to make
mistakes
right yeah it's not like shawn mendes
was out there saying like no i'm gonna
call him a hymn and a he
because he has a dick between his legs
and i get to call him whatever the [ __ ]
i want
that he that is not what he was saying
he was like oh [ __ ] that's right you are
not a he
him uh anymore and your pronoun is a day
and a damn and it slipped my mind and so
this is what he said he goes oh
uh sam smith i'm so sorry for referring
to you as a he for your jingle bell uh
introduction jingle ball introduction it
absolutely slipped my mind won't happen
again
sending you much love also absolutely
one of the funniest people i've ever met
so what's the problem no i think i think
i think that's completely appropriate
you know and i think that's all it is
right like
it i think if we could get back into
in the place of saying oh i'm sorry i
don't know about that can you tell me a
little bit more
do you mind and you know and it's and
it's perfectly okay if that person says
no
um and that person tries to find
somebody else to teach them
um or if that person has you know feels
like they they can
you know teach somebody and then that
person could apologize i'm so sorry i
didn't mean to say that
like i didn't know that was offensive
you know let's let's go through this
yeah i mean we're in this like weird
space of like
um because i think it's because the
internet too like everything has become
so
just worldly accessible man what the
[ __ ] man
this one keep going girl who's here the
child i just feel like he's been like
soaked in a lake and just dead for years
why are you so
pale it's new york man it's getting cold
i swear to god i've never been more ashy
in my life let me tell you
i'm over here like just applying thicker
creams i'm like it is
chilly out here i miss california i'm
still using the vino
i had to step it up i had to get some
actual cream i'm on that sarah vena is
there a vein i don't
know it sounds like a [ __ ] but not
it's really good for your skin yeah yeah
who's i know man i feel like i'm young
again
i don't know i uh yeah my [ __ ] legs
are ashy as [ __ ] it's it's been just
been dry as hell lately to be honest
with you
how's the house things out in l.a man
you guys are closed down again oh we
closed out as [ __ ] out here
like there's nothing there's nothing
popping out which is kind of fine i
i think like cuomo no no arson's not
cuomo who the [ __ ] is our guy
you got garcity i'm talking about como
is my guy
kobo's your guy garcetti over here like
like i said
i take i understand this virus is very
serious but this will say no biking
outside
no walking outside i'm like no
i'm sorry he said no walking no like no
walking no biking
outside i'm like that that's an order
that just is is asking to be violated
exactly like find a good medium don't
don't go ham like that bro
like you're just asking for insurgency i
i mean as a
as a physician because i feel like
everybody like dude like
the the quarantine weight gain is real
like a lot of my patients like 20
30 pounds like it is like and i and i'm
and i'm i'm employing them to like you
know like i get it you're at home
you're not moving like you used to you
have to add some kind of movement
routine in your day to
you know and try to like limit your
consumption of that bad stuff the
calories
and it is so hard so like to say no
biking no walking i'm just like
we just won't turn into wall-e people
yeah
i mean i mean for me too it's like look
i think people
it was put out too that would you be
raised and being outdoors like it
kills a lot of the virus and as long as
you're six feet away
you should be fine right so in my mind
i'm like
there has to be a balance like you got
to allow people to exercise
you know there's a that's something that
should i i
you know but allow understand to walk
outside
there's there's a lot of high-risk uh
certain situations right like
like what they're saying like places
like bars restaurants
where people you know if you drink and
you're eating
people tend to like be a little bit
speak a little louder
music the music's higher so they have to
speak over people you're basically
aerosolizing a lot of droplets so and
it's indoors so you don't have a lot of
fresh flowing air
to kind of dissipate and and essentially
dilute out
the virus concentration in the air so
it's
so yeah so i think when when you're
talking about outdoor
events you know people are a little bit
more okay with it that's why you have
all the outdoor
like comedians and stuff right like
they're doing shows and parking lots and
all that stuff because
the risk goes down a little bit as
you're spread out as you have a
flowing wind or whatever as people are
masked up and separated
so yeah no i agree with like the bars
movie theaters like we just closed down
we're closing out restaurants
on monday so that'll be tomorrow um but
yeah no it's definitely one of those
things where
it i don't know man i think it
it's gonna take a while for us to
recover from this like even like
even if if this vaccine is perfect and
everybody wants to take it which is not
the case
um you know it's gonna take a long time
to just just distribute it enough
that we could go back to business as
usual yeah
maybe like at best maybe by like next
you know
summer of 2021 um maybe
you know just there's a lot of people in
the country and a lot of places that
unfortunately want to have why is the
virus so strong during like the cold
season like what's the what's the reason
behind that because summertime they said
it was
not so bad but they said when it gets
cold it's going to be crazy like
what is that how does that work well i
mean if you think if you think about
like uh you think about the winter right
it's
you know people just have more
secretions during this time of year
right like you're
you definitely you you're colder you're
you know you get a runny nose all this
different stuff people tend to spend
more time indoors
um i think you know when it's hot and
summer time people tend to be more in uh
more outdoor spread apart
doing fun things anyways but in the
winter you're cold
you're you're you're packed together
things spread
so i don't like you know there's there's
certain there's certain things that
you know like this virus was was was as
strong like in brazil
as it was here you know i mean like we
had so like i don't think that he
necessarily killed this but i think the
change
and kind of our behavior when it gets
colder like even right now like
in new york city like it's like this
past week has been like in the 30s
to 40s sometimes 20 degrees when i was
20 degrees
you know but like or or high or low you
know low 30s
you ain't gonna do outdoor dining yeah
like you out here like nah that that
breeze cut through my clothes
i ain't doing this [ __ ] you know um so
you're to want to go indoors
they only got so many seats you're going
to sit next to each other you know and
then
things are going to spread and then
you're going to go home and you're not
going to spend a lot of
like when you're hanging out with your
friends you're not going to go out to
the park and chill
you're going to stay at each other's
house you know eating foods playing
games watching television whatever
spreading things amongst each other
going to your home spread into your
family
doing more indoor activities and things
just you know keep popping off like that
um crazy right when it got cold like it
was nuts how
how many i thought but but the holidays
too i think the spike though we got
right here
the 3000 like the the the record that we
just got i think it's
i think it's thanksgiving yeah that
makes sense yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
pretty obvious yeah because
i know that um i mean everybody was
going to meet up and start gathering for
thanksgiving
it was going to happen and so even when
i went back for thanksgiving you know
with me my brother and uh mariel but we
all got kova tested before we left and
prior to that i didn't see anybody for
like two weeks just in case yeah
yeah i felt pretty sick coming through
it's it's hard man just because there's
a lot
you know this time of year there's a lot
more travel a lot more gathering
um you know um it's it's just
and we know that shortly after that
period of that travel we start seeing
the spike if you think about it
the weekend that you caught it was
thanksgiving weekend it was a weekend
right after it because that was a fight
it was on saturday
um and then you know and then and then
your symptoms started about
uh what five days later on the friday so
it's like
so that's kind of like you were you were
kind of in that
thanksgiving spike yeah yeah
um and you're not alone like a lot of i
have a lot of friends my one of my one
of the pediatricians at my clinic
was uh unfortunately one of her sons um
came home and it was just like they
didn't have a big thanksgiving she just
had
her her husband and her sons and and i
saw her
um briefly on friday because i worked
the day after thanksgiving
and then um and then on monday they're
like oh hey so-and-so
is out you know they were tested
positive for coving
and and um did you guys have any contact
and we had to think about like contact
did we have our mask off and our
like did i have my mask off in my office
as i was working by myself
what did she come by you know all these
things that i don't think about uh but
yeah man every like there's lots of
people who are just kind of
being hit by this clue i was like [ __ ]
uh i think i saw a few people but i had
my mask on and i'm like and i was it was
outdoors
so i'm like okay that's a lower risk
situation
i'm like but i don't let them know it's
like hey turns out i have coven you know
we saw each other three days ago
yeah i wasn't symptomatic then but i
still saw you
we were outdoors i was mass but who
knows because you know even for me
because i saw
i saw khalif like two days before two
three days before i was symptomatic
uh he had a commercial coming up so if
he had kovac he would have lost money he
would have lost that job
so but because i was so paranoid about
you know going to the you know
the the tyson fight at bart's place but
i was next to him i always wore a mask
so i was like just in case and thank god
i did because
you know he got he got the uh the what's
it called that prp the the
pcr the pcr test so he got the pcr test
um like four or five times in a row
because when you're i guess like before
you
shoot a lot of these commercial things
or like movie stuff or whether it's a
that or a commercial four or five days
even before you shoot they can't keep
testing you every day
with the pcr test yeah well i mean i
i think that's the biggest lesson if
anybody like takes anything home
after this it's it's like you know it's
not about
you i mean hopefully you're okay but i
always think about like the people that
you can affect
right like exactly you have you have a
lot of friends you have a lot of like
family you have like
you know your parents and my parents
they're of a certain age
right they're vulnerable and then you
know you have loved ones who you live
very close to and i think a lot of
people do
um so it's about you know even if you in
your
in your um you know even if you're in
your sense of hubris you're like i'll be
i
you know maybe somebody you care about
well and i think that's that's
that's that's like the biggest like
that's the
i think that's the hardest takeaway for
people because it's hard to
to do things when you don't see it
directly affecting you
you know and uh when they say things
like oh well i'm young and i'll be fine
it's like that's cool you know but
what what is fine for somebody else it's
fine like for me like was
yeah physically i was okay but mentally
i was destroyed
like so was that was i fine
probably not like i've never really
faced quote-unquote depression until
recently i'm guessing that's what it was
i don't know how
i could clinically diagnose it but your
boy was [ __ ] losing his
mind dude like losing my [ __ ]
mind so could you imagine like what that
does to somebody else maybe who
isn't as mentally strong as i am right
how bad would it have been and i don't i
don't really know so there's like other
adverse effects and i think when people
think about oh i'm not being selfish
because
i'm around young people that that's a
very
loose that's very loose in terms of what
you think being selfish is
right because you're not looking at the
outward effects you're gonna have on on
the ripple effect scale right like it
they might not die but mentally they
could affect them they might lose
like job opportunities they're not gonna
be around to be around their family
there's other things besides death this
is this is the problem that i'm having
with a lot of people and this is why
also i'm disappointed that i
that i stayed there like when i when i
went there and i saw a lot of people i
should have left
but i didn't so you know that's my badge
i have to take the [ __ ] hell
and i paid for it yeah but i mean i
think i think but then you get a chance
to
come and talk to people about this right
because i mean i don't think you're
alone like i think um
all of us especially as we get into
november december right
and there's going to be like i you know
there's and there's going to be an
opportunity to see friends
family um all these people like
you know you think about the choices
that you make
and the ramifications that they'll have
and some of these are very hard choices
like
you know um you
sometimes have a family member who's
older and you don't know
if next year you'll have a chance to see
them
so you have to make choice you know and
and you know as hard as
these choices are you know i'm i'm taken
back to
kind of um earlier in the year when i
was working in the icu
and we just because of how bad the
infection was
people you you couldn't have family
members come see you when you're sick
like you have like one or two videos
like one visitor
in icu and and you know i see you as an
intensive care unit people
die there you know sometimes they get
better sometimes they die
um so just imagine people who
it's you don't even get a chance to say
goodbye to somebody you cared about
because how bad this virus is
and that's how that's the reality that's
a reality that a lot of families are
dealing with
and if we you know can
find part of you know you know take that
you know think about that
and think about the sacrifice of us
making a choice to
to leave a party to not get together
with a bunch of people
you know it it may it could save
somebody
yeah um and it and and you know and i
think that's a
that's the thing that like i think when
you're a little older and
um i i don't even want to put an age on
it but i think when you're a little bit
aware
of kind of other people when you're when
you're you start thinking about others
you know you start thinking you start
thinking about that and you're like yo i
would really love
to go hang out with all my friends from
high school because we only get to see
each other this time of year
every year but you're like maybe this
year ain't the time
yeah like even for uh this thanksgiving
we all did uh we did the
zoom thanksgiving friendsgiving thing
yeah
yeah you know we just did what we had to
do that's what it is you know
even this year man i know i'm no uh
going
going back home of course it's gonna be
super safe and
trying to see family members but you
know i want to see
our mutual friend thieves i know you're
out there you know she knocked up as
hell
but you know she's pregnant i ain't
gonna go over there you know risk
you know giving it to my future nephew
you know what i mean i can't remember no
i was supposed to say this thanksgiving
and even though i tested negative i got
a little nervous i'm like
i'm not i'm probably not she brag though
she prego you know what i mean i'll see
you next year
and you know and i think you know you
don't want to see your kid and you'll
see joey you know see that that family
you know i mean like
we have to make these sacrifices like
christmas and like stay
i'm like all right okay like yeah don't
come
i'm like okay yeah damn that's cold
brother
yeah that's cool they told me to stay my
ass home well guys
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast uh
came out clean with the cobit uh no
longer positive
but past ten days just think about you
know just just think about how it can
affect other people
aside from the death part there's just
crazy things that are happening right
now
um you know [ __ ] this guy is stupid
yoda
and then bro your your hair is about to
be like ours right
don't say that join it bro baby the
hairline
god look at that brother look at that
look at that that's naturally
aerodynamic you know what i mean
you'll be fast on your bicycle i don't
know when this full hair was going away
this [ __ ] was all patchy and [ __ ]
looked like somebody was chewing on the
back side of his head
do we want do we want to talk about your
your ability to grow a beard david look
like
like you got like three whiskers you got
like three riskers the one going up here
one go ahead throwing up the west side
side bro
actually exactly 17.
it is exactly 17 hairs
so like you like like a pretty cat look
at you you know i had to do what i had
to do
you guys and we'll see you all next time
peace